toute suspicion aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur bloquer à tout le monde
avait fait une vidéo tu as quelques mois
ça mélange entre minecraft counter
strike ce qui est assez bizarre on va
faire des lots punk rock le matin dans
le métro ok c'est parti on lui a donné
maria john est mort attention va ce
steak haché et sniper il est où là il
est mort moi bla il est mort - deux
cracks et elle a fait un bon début de
partie là c'est bien ça pourquoi mais on
est fort que dans les jeux un peu nul
quand même il m'a vu je tente in moscow
five a surpris le co ne bouge et qu'on
prend alors des de merde on va dégager
ça et ça aille au genou et tous tués
opel a même bien robert müller bien là
bien au point l'armé venir on va se
faire plaisir on va vraiment énervé nos
équipiers aller fin de la partie tout le
monde soit barrez vous
[Musique]
hopla jump shot qu'est ce qui t'arrive
et 3,69
je suis en train de jouer ma vie dans ce
[ __ ] de jeu c'est secondes farandou
une véritable vague et demi à la santé
ce pouvoir qui est en nous mais car
c'est vous les aviez des fichiers aussi
un il me on va y aller à la refuser à
pompe ou va rocher dans le tas m8 est
allé dior l'eau au revoir mais c'est pas
vrai monsieur lui les noirs et me fait
peur rien il fait peur aux placer une
fente comme ça tapait la confiance
n'était pas la journée
ce qu'il a pris il a rien vu venir
embuscades suivant au revoir voilà moi
j'avais confie comme ça les conflits pas
les cons fifa les confits de canards
jeux les bouffées rigolade live gold
malabou tumeur rigole or il à paris aa
les morts j'ai plus de vie mais j'ai vu
que j'avais un medikits alors je vais me
poser
oh [ __ ] ça marche bien on dirait que
j'ai fait l'amour et smara ben s'est
emparé de santé de quelqu'un je suivais
là dans l'ombre à il était mort t'es
mort au revoir
tu as hâte en mécanique et part sur la
tête quoi il prend la grosse tête ça y
est je la dynamite et barbe
mais voilà quand même c'est plus correct
on va réussir en ahl el béchir est de
folie c'était tellement beau au revoir
taillon mâcon des trucs sur la tête qui
les protège mon gars tu te mets tu
jusqu'en d'alizée avec leur kevlar là
moi aussi je vais du kevlar là c'est
scandaleux j'entends des tirs j'entends
un conflit et je suis le des conflits
capteurs commenté ben khedda res te
plaît pas ce mot du kevlar et vas-y que
je te plaît et e.on à toi j'aurais eu
ton kevlar chauffer pas mort en plein
fouet les là aussi ça le but du jeune y
allez on y va à un monta montagne
ailleurs ok je m'ennuie la mer cette
montagne c'est fini oui j'étais aussi
lui tire dessus il est mort le kevlar
n'a pas pu arrêter mes balles je répète
le quai malbert faire ça va je répète
[Musique]
il ya un mode doc c'est un mec alors moi
au diabète le crâne aux halles de pau
mais pas dans le son et le web avait
sondé dormir à son moteur mais de
manière continue to allez on va alors
voir au bagad à magog au milan l'autre
ketchup
c'est une cible prioritaire d'euros
atteint la arena et au lance-roquettes
il me randall ce mec aille se lance
roquettes gens vivront ces chiffres sont
limpides heures
n on va y aller olé
[Musique]
alors cet homme c'est interne énorme
hors d'elle voilà il ya des grenades et
des espions partout gens qui tirent
pourquoi elles ont du kevlar je ne
comprends pas par tüv et retrouver une
nouvelle fois dans les bois mais cette
fois on va m'appeler elle chasse emmené
l'homme 3 mais merde mois à - 2 mai qui
sera donc la prochaine victime de
terribles prédateurs home as we dare
légaux aux malouines a en fait demandé
la vega ou fait chier à la fin la prime
faire devenir un peu fort là là là assez
sous l'oeil écoute un moment j'aimerais
bien rencontrer des gens et leur
remettre une petite balle e pixelisé
dans la tête
quoi dans la tête wacom ça allait ont
filé au pistolet les gens qui nous
résistent aux iphone avant de mourir tu
fais quoi dans notre peau de mon gars
voilà j'ai fait diversion est allé pour
c'est comme le film equis mr que toi
t'as pas la fille blonde plutôt joli à
tes côtés un hula calais et bunge et 360
eurosport
[Musique]
ramallah il ya un ping de merde on est
d'accord
mais c'est sérieux là le mec il a un
casque mais regardez à la jarrie street
attendait trop tu as enlevé son [ __ ]
tu as pont l'abbé wallez avec débat mans
et ben moi je refuse de mettre 10 euros
dont sacha potins c'est hors de question
d'y qu'une petite mer une petite merde
oui mais voilà les gens c'est déjà
fonctionné désastreuses sur blockade et
7 mm d'eau ça vous a plu aux nombreux et
aussi petite surprise le site squeeze
pourrait faire ouvre ses portes demain
il ya un contingent sollicité bas soyez
présents à l'ouverture voilà ou alors
soyez au tennis j'en sais rien vous en
reparlerai dans la vidéo de demain ça
fait des mois que j'attends ça et je
suis très content du résultat j'ai hâte
que vous me fassiez de retour à l'air
bien sûr que tout le monde pis
[Musique]